this is not a euphemism
but I asked my husband to pop to the shops
and bring me home a lot of soil
and a little bit of corn
but of course he brought home
a little bit of soil and a lot of corn
and I'm really hoping it's just cause he
can't listen for shit
and not because it's indicative of a greater
issue that I need to be aware of
anyway once again
I've been distracted by my garden
cause I find that
the results of gardening lasts a lot longer
than the results of cleaning
not that I don't need to do that as well
I need to do a lot of things
this poor renovation has been seriously kicking my ass
but a week or so ago I found a bunch of
plants at the school fair for $2
and even though I don't really have any
room for any more plants
if you're selling them for $2 I will buy as many as I can carry
and normally I would just
shall we say
bribe my husband to build
me a new planter box
but I seriously think that that poor man might be at capacity
considering I've just convinced him to
renovate a 50 year old pool
with no pool renovation experience
so I'm on my own with this one and
with limited soil resources apparently
but I have an unused space behind my plant boxes
and I thought maybe I could utilise it
I added three cucumbers to the existing planter box
and back here I'm gonna add two pumpkins
three very sick looking sunflowers and
like 24 corns for some reason
anyway at this point I have no idea if they're gonna take
I might have to go in with some more soil and
kinda build it up a little bit
but they were seriously gonna die if I left
them in their containers any more
so I did my best alright?
my little garden makes me so happy
I come out here multiple times a day and just enjoy checking on it
and I need you to tell me that
I'm not the only one that likes talking to her plants
cause I swear it makes them grow more okay